I have real boobs I have real boobs I
have real boobs I have real boobs I have
real boobs I have real boobs I have real
boobs
[Music]
do a jumping jack
my name is Lily and my daddy
my name is charisma these are my boobs
I am really suspicious of Charisma I
feel like she did a little jump that was
very confident very buoyant is that
primer
my name is Jess
my boobs
coming out
hello Janiece press
hi everyone samiha the bitties
these are my boobs
I'm Ava these are my titties everyone
has really nice boobs I love boobs I do
what does everybody do for work I'm a
photographer and model I work in Tech
okay I don't work right now okay I'm a
content creator nice okay cool actor uh
cocktail and bottle service I'm a
freelance entrepreneur wow okay cool
cool okay boss ladies I'm really
suspicious of Ava right now because she
said that she's a content creator and on
my Tick Tock I've been seeing a lot of
like Filipino people just get a lot of
boob jobs recently I feel like she's the
most I'm curious how everyone's back
pain is usually terrible terrible I
don't really have a lot to carry but
like what I've noticed is that I would
slouch no matter what just because like
I don't know I'm shy but honestly like
when people talk about back pain I'm
like because maybe I'm just dead inside
and I've always had it how do you feel
about sports bras I don't know
compressed yeah I kind of like it yeah I
was gonna say I literally like it I grew
up Muslim so we were kind of told to
hide our boobs unfortunately so I'm
actually used to sports bras yeah so I
grew up doing sports a lot of soccer and
you don't want them to like jump up and
down I was like I needed something tight
yeah yeah so yeah I see her clear from
the hobby workout yeah oh yeah
on the stairs like it's like oh my God
it hurts everybody knows the booby
struggles this is hard
I've shot a lot of girls that have had
like breast augmentations even with bras
on they tend to have like a little
separation between their cleavage that
is why I'm a little suspect of Ava and
Charisma they both have great boobs
though what age would you guys say you
wear when you first noticed the male
Gates
oh it's not too deep
[Applause]
Norway and I feel like it was a little
different there because I don't know I
just I felt it more when I moved to the
US I was like yeah yeah I definitely
feel like it was like puberty like when
my body started developing and like when
I started growing boobs going in a high
school kind of like that's when I
realized I was just kidding that's when
did your guys start growing going into
freshman year I literally all middle
school I had nothing got my period that
summer and then my boobs appeared I got
double D's at 12. oh it was not fun
definitely like the seventh grade yeah
it's like crop top Queen at that point I
was like
around fourth grade because I think
that's all when I got my period so I'm
in the same cup size since then too so
yay maybe I think it was like 13 but
they weren't super big back then I took
birth control when I was I think 17. and
then it kind of grew a little bit more
and I was like nice
around 12 13 as well
um but yeah it's been the same I think
it's like maybe my birth control or just
hormones that sometimes you know they're
a little bit of voluptuous but most of
the time you know they're a little tiny
and just need a lot of push-ups yeah
um I have a question oh no no this light
change is scary I want to know when was
the last time you showed yourself some
true self-care well what if I told you
that your journey to self-love just got
a little bit more elevated and even
better it doesn't have to be a luxury in
fact Lilo is giving you 30 off select
Lilo products with code melons 30. so
what's stopping you from enjoying the
fruits of your own self-love
thank you to Lilo for sponsoring this
episode
what are you doing
um let's get back into the video
she's an actor and I used to act so I'm
like girl you are delivering wines right
now
it's still look and also she was a
little too quiet they're just perfect
like they're perfect boobies
bye I wasn't really talking too much and
probably my job maybe made people
suspicious but you know I'll I'll take
it as a compliment
well I was gonna ask you guys
um like how is your like boob pain like
when your period is about to come on I'm
tender yeah like it works if I bump into
something it's just really fun yeah even
though you're laying down it's like
that's been annoying Elizabeth was
really quiet and I noticed she also
waited till other people answered but so
did Ava yeah it's a swollen like the
nipples like no matter how easy I touch
my nipples I'm just like no how do you
feel about walking down the stairs oh I
go crazy on it actually I don't feel
like my time when we were asking the
question of walking down the stairs and
she was like oh I go crazy girl
that didn't make sense so I definitely
think it's her I take my time and if I'm
running down like I'm obviously that
tight hug you're just yeah or like
holding it just while I'm walking down
my building has an elevator so I usually
wear like socks like this this is a kind
of support yeah so and I don't have like
the biggest boobs that would jump yeah
do you think there's a stigma about fake
breasts people think you're about but if
you're getting your like self-indulged
if you're getting like any work done not
just like your breasts done but any work
in general which is unfortunate because
at the end like your autonomy is your
autonomy and if you have the money and
you have the bread yeah go go get new
boobs go get that eyebrow like so it I
think that stigma is going more towards
a younger generation yeah which is
unfortunate did you guys watch the
Barbie movie yet oh I saw yesterday in
the mood they say like anything you do
as a woman you will always be judged for
either for one reason or the other yeah
yeah sure especially where I come from
two it's like if you get boob surgery
they think you're like trying to be like
a porn star or something that's like The
Stereotype yeah and like people get it
like you could have cancer in one again
does anyone know anyone who's gotten
their boobs done in like your friend
groups yeah so many yeah I don't know
anything as a photographer like I've met
so many girls so like yeah does anyone
everyone have a boob that's bigger than
the other yeah
I think just the areola but I don't
think I've noticed my titties different
maybe I just don't look at it like that
but yeah which boob is it my left my
right my left left my left one left
Ariel is a little bigger do you guys
have a favorite boob the left
I just recently started loving my boobs
so I'm paying more attention because I'm
now not really like back then so I don't
know if I have a favorite yet do you
guys get asked if they're fake a lot
[Music]
I definitely asked in the modeling
industry like getting changed like I was
like 16 people like you're boob sick I'm
like do I have money to get a boob job
at 16 now absolutely no these are mine I
think Janiece might be the mole because
she said that people have suspected her
of having plastic surgery done in the
past so she might have fake boobs so I
got boobs really young and I think in my
experience that people do feel like they
can approach you it made me feel like my
body wasn't mine for many years people
would make comments or like all of a
sudden boys would be really nice to me
and then I'm like oh do they actually
like mirror they want to touch my boobs
under the bleachers
um
Jess was very passionate and I was like
she has some booby baggage so that's why
I could not vote for her but I mean even
like on the internet like people just
say things and it's like chill
foreign
[Music]
what
oh you want them to go like And
subscribe
[Music]
you heard them they said go like And
subscribe to this channel if you want
more
I was thinking of Jess something in my
subconscious just like maybe it's her
my second guess was Ava and she was
still in with the bunch so I was like we
gotta get her out
sorry I'm really suspicious
me
oh thanks
it's a compliment I mean this top that I
wore today definitely made them push up
a little bit more and made them look
good a lot more than normal so maybe
that's why
okay one two three
we don't have to only one person is
supposed to keep playing two
that is not the majority so that means
the game
if the Box turns green the five of you
have correctly voted the mole out the
box turns in
mole is still among the five of you and
the ball wins One
Two
Three music
one
two
three
oh my God
[Music]
thank you thank you
yeah
I was baffled I was Bamboozled trust
issues why did I not ask her if she was
wearing a bra why didn't I ask her to
jump oh I wish some of us raised our
hands more I had no idea like she was
not on my radar at all like she played
that game so good I grew up not really
having big boobs at all when I first hit
puberty I was like 11 or 12. my mom told
me they would grow just wait till you
get older it never happened I never
developed them at all like my stomach
and boobs were the same when I was funny
and I just wanted to get my boots done
because I wanted to feel more confident
and I never was insecure about it like
to the point where I got bullied about
it and stuff I just to me I wanted to
feel what feels more feminine to me
which is kind of curvy and like balance
my body out more and I haven't regretted
it ever since they look great girl you
gotta yeah
I think it's important to feel
comfortable with who you are that is
doing a surgery then you should do it if
you know it's for yourself and not
because everyone else wants to I think
that's also very important I got a BBL
so period girl you do that and if I had
the money I'd do it too so yeah if you
want to get boobies come join the Big
Titty Committee but I'll warn you
running is gonna not be so easy anymore
wow that's a lot of money you guys
should come in yeah
[Applause]